Ừ
ông kia nhanh tay mình tạo thành mình
tác cái sau đó mình xóa luôn cái tin
nhắn đấy mà thế mà muộn bấm vào tìm được
ý
ê kê trả các bạn còn mai thì on sớm mình
thì cũng vẫn như mọi khi vẫn hồi hộp thứ
bây giờ kém hơn ngồi soạn bài đó thứ Xem
lại video thêm một lần nữa con thứ công
nhận cũng mình cũng
anh cũng khá bận Khi mà dành nhiều thời
gian cho việc dạy này
về chưa để lỗi là mức độ là theo kiểu là
nghiêm trọng như đi làm và phải đi làm
thì ạ nó liên quan đến cả tiền bạc các
thứ thì mình còn phải nghiêm túc hơn nữa
mình phải
nó có gì đó Kiểu nó áp lực hơn kiểu thế
còn cái này thì nghĩ ra thì
Ừ mình vẫn có trách nhiệm với nó nhà nó
vẫn là cái thứ mà mình tâm huyết nên là
vẫn còn sự gì đó thoải mái hơn
Xin
chào bạn kìa lần đầu xem like
ạ Bây giờ là thằng 11 nghỉ ở các bạn bây
giờ cũng trong giai đoạn cũng thi cử
thôi thứ
thật là lý tưởng nhất vẫn là các bạn
phải học cái này từ hồi mà mới dịch kiểu
thế để mà bây giờ là con nhà giãn dịch
rồi Lúc này các bạn thì đi học lại rồi
đúng thì các bạn có Thậm chí có thể đi
làm được tập luôn cái này quá ngon còn
bây giờ thì bây giờ các bạn bây giờ thì
không thể mong là các bạn lại dịch canh
lại nữa nó ngoan nhưng mà bây giờ học
rồi thì cứ theo thôi nhưng mà các bạn
phải biết
gọi là khó bạn cũng nhắn tin mình hỏi đó
là kiểu hãy sắp xếp thời gian như thế
nào những và kiểu vừa học vừa làm ảnh
các thư thứ như thế
Ừ thì à mình ra mình sắp xếp cá lắm kiểu
mình không biết phân bổ này ra nó lắm
thời gian biểu của mình cứ loạn hết cả
lên
chắc là mình người nào thì bạn chất ai
cũng sẽ còn 24 24 giờ chẳng ai hơn ai
thì em mới giàu nhà nghèo thì tại sao
người giàu người ta Lại lại có thể hiểu
tận dụng được thời gian như thế bởi vì
em muốn lúc họ làm được nhiều việc cũng
như là họ sắp xếp thời gian đã hợp lý họ
cũng có họ có thể không có thời gian
nghỉ ngơi thời gian nghỉ ngơi họ ít hơn
em gái con ạ mình thì à
Ừ mình thì kiểu mình chả vẫn chưa tận
dụng được nhiều thời gian Nên mình vẫn
chưa giàu kiểu là gì ạ
à à
anh
không hôm trước à Hôm trước không
không ngon gặp luôn
một câu hỏi rất nhiều câu hỏi rất nhiều
cày thơ cần chia sẻ đối ngoại thì
Ừ chắc em bây giờ mình cũng tranh thủ
trả lời mấy câu hỏi sớm ở
mày có hỏi mà không liên quan kiến thức
lắm thì mình sẽ trả lời
ở đầu tiên là việc về việc học bù học bù
đồng mạng có bạn bảo mình là công chức
nghỉ thì họ bù Thực ra thì mình có trả
lời ngay trong bình luận ấy rồi đó là
mình không thích kiểu cậu dạng là kiểu
thay đổi một cái lịch gì đó mình nên để
nó cũng định mình không nên kiểu
hôm
hôm nay kiểu thứ ba không học thì thứ tư
học không nên như thế thác đổ lệch thất
thường như thấy rất là nhiều bạn nó sẽ
không không theo được và nhiều bạn còn
không nắm được cái nick đấy anh Thành ra
mình ghét việc thay đổi lệch
tiếp theo là
áo kiểu
trung hòa hôm đấy nhớ hôm nay cuối tuần
thì vậy nên thành ra cậu cũng thoải mái
thôi
anh nói chung mà mình không khắt khe về
việc học bù lại lắm
cho các bạn nếu mà nghỉ thì tranh thủ
làm thêm bài tập có ông vẫn còn chưa nộp
nhiều hơn chưa Lâu lắm
Ừ cái thì
khi
làm bài tập như dành thời gian cho thứ
khác Đồng Hoa ở tiểu học lập trình ngày
bản chất là
các bạn tự học vẫn ăn nhiều mà nhưng
mình đã nói các bạn phải tự học ổn
anh em mình sẽ không có khái niệm học bù
lại lắm
a tiếp theo là
à à
em có bạn hỏi về cái vụ là đổi tên bếp
hả Nói chung là gặp những cải cách để mà
cậu
vào được nick người khác hay ạ thật chứa
đá admin ra khỏi group và vân vân vân ờ
ờ
ở trên Facebook Bản chấp thì nhựa những
bạn ở biết rồi thì bản chất cái đấy nói
không phải là hack Từ giờ cũng tìm một
cái lỗ hổng mà cái kiểu những cái bấc
của thằng Facebook đấy Nhưng mà thường
Bây giờ có khái niệm vợ chích cơ Tất cả
những kiểu tìm mạch cái mẹo vặt mấy cái
kiểu thủ thuật để mà lách để mà kiểu tố
cáo này hay ở cậu gửi mấy cái form hỗ
trợ của thằng Facebook hoặc Facebook với
thực là nhiều cái nó dùng bằng máy tính
để mà nhận diện chữ nó không dùng màng
người lắm Bởi vì nó đang làm dịch vụ cho
hơn tủi người nha nó không dùng người để
mà hỗ trợ các bạn với vụ đấy nó sẽ dùng
AE mà sẽ dùng boss tệ mà kiểu duyệt
nhanh qua các phone thì bây giờ ông chỉ
cười được đúng cái kiểu các thứ thì thì
ông lấy được có khoảng người ta nếu mà
ông người được đầy đủ thông tin rồi đầy
đủ giấy tờ ô shop các thứ vân vân để
mình biết qua như thế mình cũng không
rành bên này lắm nhưng mà
đấy Gọi checker chứ cũng gọi không ai
gọi nó là thích cơ ở với ông là tự nhận
đấy hacker Mấy ông đấy kiểu người ông đi
loài người thôi chúng mày ông ấy có biết
về tình duyên thì cốc hãy thử đâu ạ
anh tờ ra trường nên đi làm như nào bạn
thấy
Nghe câu này của bạn đầy hơi rộng quá
nên mình cũng xin phép trả lời rộng luôn
ở đầu tiên thì nếu mà bạn lại đang nói
việc là ra trường khi mà bạn đi học ở
trường đúng
Chờ
Đợi mình tí mình mình con chó đấy Ờ
ừ ừ ừ ừ
À thì ra trường
Đợi mình tí
[âm nhạc]
xác định ai mắng thế nào Không mình thì
chỉ có nào cũng cả không phải dấu hiệu
lệnh kiểu mình đang
mình đang xem mấy cái kênh boss đó và ở
trên YouTube dạy về cách kiểu dạy chó
như thế nào có thứ thứ đi đứng nhiều lúc
cũng bờ cám cửa nhiều lúc bị mất nó cửa
sủa tỉnh giấc mất ngủ cậu cũng có nhưng
mà kiểu chó thì ra là kiểu về cơ bản nó
thông minh
A và mình phải
sự kiên nhẫn chó ở loài nó rất là kiên
trì kiên trì cả việc nên và số nên là
mình phải kiên nhẫn giỏi hơn nó theo
kiểu ở mình phải kiên nhẫn bơ là đi
không không Cứ mỗi lần Nó rên rỉ như thế
thì mà mình kiểu kiểu dạng kiểu thôi cho
nó vào xong mới kiểu phe nó cứ từ từ thì
lần sau nó lại riêng xịt
Ừ thế này là mình sẽ phải kiểu kiên nhẫn
đủ thứ mình đi Hơi sai một tí chắc là
cũng do một phần cho bạn bạn làm nhà nữa
bạn ở nhà thì kiểu rất là à thoải mái
kiểu Hơi tí cậu ra dỗ dành Nó thứ Đúng
rồi Con hư tại mẹ rồi thì
Ừ thì mình sẽ phải biết huấn luyện nó từ
mấy tháng đầu thì nó về nhà ấy
Anh Trung Hà Kiều khi mà mình
sau khi mà mình xem cái kênh pops Đa kia
người ta giải thích dễ hiểu và cũng như
thấy từ trước nay mình tượng thôi Hồi bé
mình bố mẹ mình nuôi chó nhưng mà toàn
chơi kiểu lại không nói được thì tần các
bạn cho biết cái kiểu này rồi kiểu dạng
lại kiểu nó nó mà hiểu đi vệ sinh sai
chỗ đánh nó kêu Kiểu gì nó giấu đấy đánh
nhau Nó kiểu biết là không vừa đi đấy
nữa như thế sai đối ngoại đấy thì
mình phải biết cách nói cho mình cũng
phải đang học buổi thấy học nhiều vãi
chưởng với cái việc dạy chó nhưng mà ạ
Thấy cũng đỡ hơn
Em đã đỡ hơn đấy nghẽn chị mình dậy được
nó cách không sủa cá thử nó ơi
chỉ mỗi tội đi vệ sinh Cũng vớ vẩn thôi
ạ
à à
Ờ Ờ
hôm trước mình còn nó qua một tí về
marquezine nữa cả Bác Đinh Thế nghe mình
mới xin nói qua thôi
toàn bộ những cái kiến thức sẽ được ra
vẫn còn sơ sài nhưng mà mình không muốn
đi sâu của nó lắm vì ở kiểu mình áp thì
mình áp dụng cái đấy ít cực nên là không
quan trọng và đầy lắm các bạn về sau Cốc
Cốc về thì các bạn sửa Các bạn nhìn thấy
cái kết quả các bạn sẽ hình dung được
ờ ờ quay quay lại về cái câu hỏi của bạn
này ra trường nên đi làm thế nào đúng ạ
Ở cái việc ra trường của bạn nếu mà ra
trường đại học Thì mình khuyên thật là
các bạn bị yếu về cái thực hành cho nên
là trong khoảng thời gian ở trên trường
này thì các bạn
ngoài học lý thuyết ở trên trường ra thì
các bạn phải dành thời gian để tự làm
cái 1 hoặc 2 sản phẩm Vợ pap vô check
mình từng nói nó sản phẩm kiểu best
forex là sản phẩm kiểu nó quy mô nhỏ bé
bé
và nó theo sở thích cá nhân kiểu thế
thẩm áp dụng các kiến thức các bạn đã
học Đấy không phải về mỗi ngành Công
nghệ thông tin mà mà nhiều ngành khác
cũng có thể tương tự Thế mẹ bạn cần phải
cổ kinh nghiệm gì ấy ngoài kinh nghiệm
tế là mà các bạn ngoài đi thực tập các
thứ thứ các bạn cũng nên tự làm một cái
gì đó sản phẩm riêng cho mình ở nhà đúng
họ tự ngồi mình mò các từ thứ để mà học
hỏi thêm đấy Xong rồi Để thứ có thứ mà
khoe khi đi phỏng vấn cũng như thể hiện
mình có đam mê với cái này này chứ không
phải là kiểu anh em lỡ chọn kiểu em nghe
nói lương cao nên em chọn
ừ ừ
à Còn nếu mà các bạn theo ở bên Cao đẳng
nghề Giống như mình rồi thì các bạn hoàn
toàn thực hành được rồi thì các bạn Mình
đi thực tập sớm thôi các bạn à Nên Nhưng
gửi CV đi được tập nhiều không không nên
kiểu
ngại không nên kiểu à Mình hướng dẫn các
bạn với cv có từ thứ rồi đúng không ạ
ờ ờ Còn nếu mà bạn đấy Hỏi về việc là
kết thúc với khóa học này của mình thì à
Đi làm được không em đi làm như thế nào
thì mình cũng từng nói rồi khóa học cơ
bản này thì các bạn về các bạn khi nó
đúng là cỡ hạn như hợp cậu là các bạn sẽ
rất khó để đi thực tập cũng như là đi
làm
các bạn sẽ chị hình dung được à lập
trình này như thế nào và các bạn có phù
hợp với ngày này không thôi còn nếu mà
các bạn muốn đi thực tập theo ngành này
muốn kéo ngày này thì các bạn bắt buộc à
Một là học khóa nâng cao từ ra nó hơi
khó một tí
các bạn nên tự làm thêm những cây sản
xuất các thứ thứ rồi Xin đi được tập
cũng được
Ẩm Thực tập áo kiểu không đưa mẹ
không không đòi hỏi được lúc này Có
lương đâu còn nếu các bạn muốn thực sự
là muốn có lương thì cả bảy tám triệu
luôn giống như cậu anh em đã có 15 thí
nghiệm kiểu thế thì các bạn với buộc
phải cậu có một cái sản phẩm xã Hồ kết
hợp với một cái gì ở Sự giống như cái
khóa nâng cao mình thì sẽ kết hợp một
phen word này đang từ từ thì mới hiểu à
Ừ đúng rồi kiểu kết thúc khóa này các
bạn kiểu gì cũng sẽ phải làm một cái một
cái trang web mà Đấy cũng là một forex
đấy đúng thì các bạn khoe khi mà phỏng
vấn
áp tiện thế tôi sẽ chửi luôn sinh viên
về vụ phỏng vấn đấy ở ngay trên đây
từ hôm trước học sinh viên của tôi kiểu
khoe em nộp CV hiểu ba tháng nơi xong
rồi em cũng đi phỏng vấn rồi nghỉ một
vài nơi gọi em đi cũng đi Xong rồi em
kiểu trời phỏng vấn họ báo ổn rồi họ mời
em đi làm rồi em không đi em lại đi
phỏng vấn chỗ khác nữa kiểu cửa thế sau
rồi Kiểu ông ấy bạn Tại sao nó làm theo
ông bà đã em buồn có kinh nghiệm phỏng
vấn cậu có hỏi là câu nói rất vu vơ cơ
thể nghe gối ông ấy nói dòng không khác
gì mà đông fatboy từ cậu có kiểu
passport kêu
đi làm công ty người ta cậu mất thời
gian phỏng vấn mình mất niềm tin thứ thứ
Ừ ông ấy cũng sẽ được vào sổ đen của các
chị em HR thiệu với Thế là có thể đó anh
em nhưng mà tôi thường ngày thời chị em
nhiều hơn
Anh ơi khuyên các bạn phải không nên
kiểu thế và cái phỏng vấn kinh nghiệm
phỏng vấn Tôi thấy phỏng vấn nó không
khác gì khi các bạn đi
ở nhà hẹn hò với những hẹn hò gặp mặt
cặp Kiểu thế à
thì các bạn sẽ
có thể chỉ ra những cái điểm tương đồng
của phù hợp của mình về công việc đấy
với công ty đấy
ông nêu ra những cái thế mạnh của mình
em à đương nhiên là không nên kiểu tự
kiêu quá không lên chém gió à
Ừ nhưng mà cũng không phải tỏ ra bí ẩn
quá làm gì cả
em à Cái này không hẳn hẹn hò lắm thế
này giống như lời cậu đi Mai mua cho cờ
lấy vợ lấy chồng ấy nó Nó kiểu nó là một
cái sự hợp tác lâu dài mà Tôi thấy là
cái việc nó không khác những gì đi phỏng
vấn cả à
ở những thành ra là kiểu mấy ông nha cần
cần kiểu nghiêm túc với nó cũng nhờ cũng
thể hiện mình có thứ
bà và cái quan trọng đó là mấy ông phải
cảm thấy mình xứng đáng với cái công ty
đấy mày không bị tăng người đăng ký vào
các thứ không Nhìn mấy ông cũng chỉ bị
từ chối thôi mà càng bị từ chối nhiều
mấy cũng cam bị nhụt chí không nhỏ giống
như đi tỏ tình cảm với ông rõ ràng mà
à không phải nói là kiểu mà ông không
thể với được cô ấy Nhưng mà quan trọng
là mấy ông
đang chưa thể hiện được mình xứng đáng
với cô ấy cảm ạ
Tôi tôi đang nói trước thì khía cạnh một
thằng con trai tôi không biết mấy bạn
gái nghĩ như nào Nhưng mà kiểu Nếu bây
giờ xử mấy ông muốn điều vợ xinh vợ cậu
Tài giòi Vợ Duyên giá nó thực sự mì ông
vẫn vẫn phải thể hiện mình có gì ở xứng
đáng với cô ấy không nên nói mấy câu
chung chung kìa em chỉ có trái tim này
kiểu ạ
U60 cậu một ông ông nghe cái vụ là cậu
gì à
túp lều tranh với 2 Trái Tim Vàng kiểu
thế
mày cái đấy nó còn mơ hồ mông lung á nếu
không phải thể hiện cái gì đó rõ ràng
hơn để người ta tin tưởng mấy ông thì
cái phỏng vấn Lâm Thế nếu không thể kêu
ông chưa có kinh nghiệm cũng như là chưa
thể hiện được đam mê của ông như một ông
cũng mồm cũng nói em sẵn và tâm huyết
với nó các thứ không ai tin cả đống
ngoạn không ai tin cả
nhà mình có dậy sớm không ạ Ừ
Ừ mình Đêm Qua
sáng hôm qua bị con chó đánh thức lúc 3
giờ sáng rồi mình thức đến 12 giờ rồi
mình ngủ Ngủ đến tầm cần bây giờ thì
mình dạy nè Mình không biết được phải
dậy sớm của bạn sẽ đúng ở trên cái múi
giờ ở nào Nhưng mà chắc chả làm mình
sinh hoạt kiểu như thế không phải là con
người giàu với không phải con người
thành công rồi
cho nên tôi không bao giờ khuyên mày ông
về cái việc là giờ giấc sinh hoạt với
tôi sinh hoạt cũng chán lắm Tôi chỉ
khuyên được mấy ông về cái vụ là kiểu
thời một lúc tôi làm được nhiều việc
cũng như là cậu tôi là mọi thử nó có và
hiệu quả
à à
Ừ đấy tôi trả lời tương đối không ạ Anh
ơi Trường dậy tí thon
mà mình muốn học xanh Cái ngôn ngữ khác
vân vân thì thế nào ạ ờ
Ừ cái này nếu tôi từng nói với khá nhiều
sinh viên đó sẽ ra trường dậy gì Các bạn
cũng nên học cái đấy đã theo kiểu là các
bạn
Anh hiểu rõ thế nào ngôn ngữ lập trình
từ đầu đến cuối một một cái đã bởi vì a
bao mình cũng phải học cũng như à Có
người để hỏi có người dạy mình thì tội
gì không ạ Hay mình tự học đấy Sau đó
mình ngày nghỉ sang cái khác thì vẫn
được mà không ạ ạ
em học sinh cậu cộng để dễ nhảy sang xi
sắt tại sao không nghĩ việc tay thon thì
vẫn sẽ nhảy sang phía xác mình thấy kiểu
nó nói chung là cái việc mà các bạn bị
thích cái ngôn ngữ nào hơn đấy
anh tỉa nó bị Hơi bị sai rồi Kiểu dân
lập trình nông dân lập trình không phải
là biết tất cả có một các ngôn ngữ nhưng
mà ngôn ngữ nạn nghề sang được bởi vì
kiểu nó nó non nó chỉ cậu nó nào rất
giống nhau cùng lắm là chỉ khác nhau về
kinh nghiệm hay cỡ là mình chưa biết hàm
ở bên kia là hàm gì có từ vân vân
giống như bây giờ tôi chuẩn bị chạy mấy
ông về ra Switch dạy lập trình ra switch
Ê bà từ đấy tìm à các bạn nhỉ xanh tết p
các bạn hiểu thế nào là ngôn ngữ lập
trình này không ạ Đấy nghĩa là khi mà
song p tôi không dậy lại thế nào ngôn
ngữ lập trình TP nữa nhớ các bạn vẫn sẽ
hiểu Đấy nó nó kéo một lúc tôi dậy một
phát hạ hai ngôn ngữ lập trình đấy Ở
trong tài khóa học này đúng không ạ thì
mấy ông chẳng thấy có gì sai đó khi mấy
ông học xong rồi Nếu thấy kiểu nó rất là
bình thường
bộ
đồ ăn xong thấy có chọn lọc
a Talent Talent là kiểu Tài Năng à
Chỉ Vì Yêu ngoài chả triển vọng có thiếu
thứ
mình mình bà sẽ có buổi bảo vệ đoán chắc
là cũng lần này cũng sẽ có chấm đấy ấy
có chấm các được trả cũng có vinh danh
khen thưởng thứ không chưa biết khen
thưởng gì Thôi sự như thế Trang kêu gọi
được một bên nào đó khen thưởng chẳng
hạn vui nha
Mình vẫn đang rất hào hứng của người cái
vụ đấy
ừ ừ
Ừ mình đang học web như mình Chữ copy
giống thêm vào các thứ ổn không Ờ trả
lời cho câu mày của bạn có thể Cái thứ
mà mình cũng biết nói luôn ở đây
cho các bạn biết khái niệm khác biệt
giữa code ơ với Dash là gì không ạ ờ ờ
Ê cu đơ với nét nhiều người sẽ rất bị
nhầm với khái niệm này
a
bit là viết tắt của dialup ơi đúng không
ai cũng nghĩ ra là cả hai đường cỡ cốt
đều lập trình
Nhưng mà thực sự thì cái cái này nó bị
khát một tí
Ừ cái cốc đầu ấy mà chết là dịch ra Thu
là người có cốt yếu rapper dịch ra là
người phát triển đối ngoại các bạn nếu
mà dịch ra thì các bạn đã thấy khác rồi
người gõ Cốt nó ra nào giống như là kiểu
Mì Gõ văn bản vậy giống kiểu thư ký Vậy
cậu thay vì mình ngồi gõ văn bản thì
mình gõ mặt Cốt nó là như nào đó là
những người hay đi copy Cốt về và chỉ
biết copy code với xài thôi chứ không
hiểu được thực sự của nó có tác dụng gì
cũng không biết tối ưu nó cũng không
biết chỉnh sửa nó vân vân và cũng không
phát cũng không viết được ra những cái
mới những cái mà không có ở trên mạng để
mà coffee
anh không phát triển thêm được tính năng
mới thì đấy à cô order order thì ra bây
giờ rất nhiều công ty vẫn đang thuê nhé
vẫn có theo kiểu là sao là trong trường
hợp của công ty làm ra được những kẻ
phần mềm
ờ ờ
làm ra những cái kiểu
ở phần mềm từ lâu rồi và họ muốn nhân
bản và phần mềm ấy lên
và sửa sửa một vài chỗ phần mềm đấy Bây
giờ nếu mà gọi lại cái ông Lập trình cũ
thì ông ấy lừa và ông ấy kiểu ngại theo
các thứ thì thường ở công ty sẽ Quê ông
cu đơ về để mà copy code kiểu chị thay
một vài chỗ thôi để sang phiên bản mới
cậu thế đấy thì thường lại thôi ông cu
đơ về để làm bụng đấy
ở chỗ ngồi gõ lại cốt rồi mà ngồi copy
code các từ hướng thôi sao cho nó chạy
được được có đơn rồi cả lương nữa chị
bảy tám triệu không hơn nữa cả sao dù
ông làm bao nhiêu năm thử nghiệm Tại sao
lại như thế cùi dìa ông cố và phát triển
thêm được cái gì đâu ông kiểu ngày ngày
thì có cốt mà nó không ạ Thế này là mấy
ông đừng có bao giờ
nghe lệnh sâu rồi cái con đường cu đơ
đấy tôi từng quen rất nhiều ông mang
tiếng nhà là
soi kèo
hai ba bốn năm kinh nghiệm chí là về sau
tôi gặp lại ông đấy thì anh yêu lên
thành 5 6 năm kinh nghiệm không ạ
anh cột trình cốt của người vẫn thế ông
ấy chỉ biết cốc cốc các thứ tư thì ông
đấy Đúng là cô đơ ông ấy không phát
triển thêm áo mới không tối ưu được cốt
ông ấy chị Cốt lại những cái gì mà ông
ấy đã biết đấy Ông ấy không tò mò ông
không tìm hiểu thêm cái gì cả ví dụ bây
giờ Tiền hình Bây giờ tôi sẽ dậy người
Ông làm cái trong các bản hàng về sau
mấy ông chỉ biết làm đúng mức ở trong
web bán hàng đấy ốp đi ôp lại ông chỉ
làm được mỗi thế thôi ông không nhảy
sang cho ghen tin tức ông không làm được
cái kiểu làm thêm tính năng mới âm chị
làm lại những cái thứ mà mình đã từng
học thì đế quốc đâu đúng không ạ
đến lớp ơi thì nó sẽ ra Cậu càng nhạy
cảm phát triển dần lên kinh nghiệm học
họ thêm không phải học hỏi thêm cả một
ngôn ngữ mới mà sẽ ra kiểu đi sâu thêm
về ngôn ngữ của mình kiểu dạng là tối ưu
hơn các thứ thứ thì các bạn cũng hình
dung dần rồi đó ạ
ừ ừ
Anh
quay hôm nay lên đến tận 140 bạn
Ừ chắc là có vẻ có nhiều bạn thấy đang
nhảy sang bên ngôn ngữ lập trình với vẻ
hào hứng nhưng mà Tuyền người mới người
cũ thì mình cũng xin phép trả lời các
bạn có hỏi là
ờ ờ Ok
khi trả lời xong rồi ngoại sao trong ccs
mình sẽ nói ngang qua sao trong CS thì
thì có bạn hỏi mình về cái này mình sẽ
ví dụ các bạn luôn ở đây
nếu các bạn thấy ở đây mình mình đang để
cho tất cả tất cả chữ đám viết thường
không ạ thì mình sẽ ghi thêm một cái ở
đây nó sao này và đây sẽ là phone
các fansite
Anh không có ý
khi viết thêm sẽ đến bây giờ gì cho quân
sự mới nổi rồi tôi thì tạm mà bên này
nhé
Thật sự đây mình có thể a a
abc này
thể H1 này
Abc tới trạm này
A5 sẽ thấy hai cái nó khác biệt đồng
ngoan ạ Ừ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ thêm size
nó này
sao nó đã sử mình muốn cho tất cả các
tất cả mọi cái đều có gạch chân được ạ
thì nó sẽ là mình sẽ dùng hạt
sao là để thể hiện đó cho mình sẽ chọn
tất cả cả các thẻ động cơ Thế dụng là
underwrite
đó tại đây tác dụng của sao ạ
ở đó tiếp theo
nhạc Khmer còn lại mình xin phép cuối
giờ trả lời nhé bây giờ vào buổi học mới
rồi
bây giờ mình chuyện mình trả lời mấy câu
Hôm trước có phải bạn hỏi thứ nhất là
bạn ấy hỏi là bây giờ em có muốn có một
cái video trận chứa một cái 13 hoặc là
giống như hôm trước tôi từng khoe mấy
ông cải trang cái sinh của tôi nó tự
phát nhạc Trở lại tự phát nhạc ở đây này
Đây đúng không ạ
anh cứ vào tự động phát nhạc này thì làm
như thế nào đối ngoại thì đầu tiên là
cái cái cái này là iPhone phim nên tí
thôi sẽ chia sẻ của Ông đúng là iPhone
và tự động cho nó tự động bật ở như thế
nào Nếu mà còn về mặc định của HTML thì
sẽ có công nhớ là sẽ có video này hoặc
là mp3
mp4 hoặc 13 đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ có
khái niệm này Tôi vừa tra xong vừa phải
trả lại ví dụ kiểu như này chẳng hạn
ờ
background-video CS này
lại cho mình xem cốt này cái cốt
cốt là để cho cả cả cái trang web Nó là
cái video trong lòng rất là hay và ấn
nút sau hai nút lai này thì nếu Để ý kỹ
ở đây nhá Thì cái thẻ video này có thêm
chữ chứ Em thuộc tỉnh autoplay là nó sẽ
tự động bật nhưng mà
còn về cái việc mà
Ừ cái hay ở đây Tôi muốn chia sẻ mấy ông
thêm đó là mấy ông vừa rồi thấy rõ ràng
là con nút play và power đây đúng không
ạ Và cái nút này nó khác với cái nút
bình thường của một cái video đúng ạ Cái
nút video kiểu để mà ông kiểu chạy đây
đây mà chạy thuần của
đây từ thử cho mẹ em xem nhé á
em
tắm rồi này à
Em
hãy tôi cho mấy ông một cái video thì
mới ông sẽ dễ hình dung hơn
ừ ừ
à à
em có mấy ông sẽ thấy à Kể cái nút Play
của nút playhead power của một cái video
mà sẽ có kiểu dạng như thế này đầy ngoạn
nó khác với cái nút này cái nút này lại
viết bằng ra Suite để thử hôm nay mình
sẽ học đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ thì thì cái cái ra Swift hôm nay mình
học thì mình sẽ mình sẽ nói qua ra squat
có tác dụng là gì Một loa hết nhân đợi
Đợi mình tí mình trả lời mình cái câu
này đã
hơi nhiều Có họ Nhưng mà thực ra bài
không mai tao ra cũng cũng tương nồi ít
Bình sẽ dạy bài hôm nay
em mới chị làm quen đâu mà tương đối ít
thôi Ờ tương tự vì mấy ông làm được cả
13 nhé 13 lòng tương tự thôi
tiếp theo là À đúng rồi Cái cái vụ
iPhone này nếu mà Mấy ông muốn autoplay
hòa tôi chỉ trông cảm mẹo khi mà nhúng
một kẹt Lại đít của soudcloud như này
nữa Tự nhiên hôm này.tôi mò để mà làm ra
cái vụ này đây thì tôi chỉ cho bé không
Tại sao tự nhiên phải nói cái vụ
soudcloud Việt soudcloud nóng nhúng thì
nó chỉ có nhúng nhúng được
mở bài bài hát bình thường chứ nó không
cho nhúng nó không cho nhóm like Nếu mấy
ông ngõ ngồi mò thì mông Sẽ Biết điều
đấy Tại mình mình thường nha ấn chia sẻ
không ạ cần chia sẻ này em này đúng
không ạ Các bạn thấy cốt này nó sẽ ra
cái cốt để máy nhúng một cái một cái bài
bài hát về tôi thử chạy cho mấy ông anh
Ừ
đúng rồi tí mình chia sẻ cả nhúng video
chứ thúc luôn
ý là như này đúng không muốn phải tự
autoplay gì tôi để cái này và thực nếu
mày ông Để ý kỹ thì nó lạnh xóa xóa cái
đít này bị tư này nếu Để ý kỹ thì trên
thanh trên cái
v-app LC là này nó đã có chứa những cái
mà Mấy ông cần rồi đó là trách này check
Thẻ Bài hát này kìa thế ID bài hát này
có lâu rồi không có trọng này autolike
bằng chu này tất cả nó sẽ kiểu tự động
phát đó ngoan sống còn thêm những cái
thuộc tính khác nữa thi bây giờ giả sử
là sử là bây giờ tôi quay lại về cái
việc mà
ở đây tôi chỉ cho mấy ông cách để mò một
cái gì đó mới ông thích đây là sử là tôi
muốn nhúng cả một cái planet mày về Đồng
hoặc giống như cái cái này của tôi này
đúng ạ thì ấn vào này Tuấn chia sẻ này
không ạ Mấy ông rõ là không thấy rõ ràng
không thấy cái phần nhúng đóng ngoặc với
ông nhưng mà tôi dân công nghệ tôi không
bỏ cuộc Nhìn kiểu thế thôi không bỏ cuộc
đâu ông ạ Tôi làm cách nào thì các bạn
sẽ như tôi vừa nói đó là Ê mày ông thấy
rõ ra là bài hát về jack cắm hoa vào đây
Ai đi của cái bài hát đấy Thì bây giờ
mình khử hai cái này là playlist xong
rồi ID của planet thì có chạy được không
đây tôi sẽ ấn inspect cho mấy ông như
thế này với ông sẽ bấm vào bên Network
như thế này số ngồi ấn vào thích Hair
pack này để làm gì để bắt được các truy
vấn của cái thằng này khi khi mà mình
làm gì là sửa mình bấm vào một grill-it
rồi đúng không ạ Mình mình ấn
Ờ Ờ
mình ấn thích như này chẳng ạ và mấy ông
để kỹ ở đây à
ừ nóng để ý kĩ đây nó có một cái ID này
Ừ tao để tôi mở theo kiểu như này mới
ông nhìn rõ hơn đây với ông thấy rõ ra
là tôi vừa thích đây
Ừ cái cây số nhà nó lại điên đấy Đây
chính là ID của planet của tôi và tôi sẽ
khai hạ lyrics vào đây này vào đây đây
lít đấy
thôi tôi chạy thử nhé
ở đó
Ừ nếu thấy lời nói đúng không
ở đó đó mấy ông vừa
em vừa gần nghĩa là cái này không hẳn là
mất gì cả chẳng qua là lách một cách để
Lách qua được kiểu cách làm làm gì đó
đúng không ạ
Ừ
thôi Anh tắt thông báo đấy chứ Tôi rõ
ràng là tôi chỉnh chế độ là cái tôi
chỉnh chế độ là kiểu An ah Mony này
không hiểu tại sao nó vẫn Bách qua được
nó vẫn thông báo tràn lan thằng terim
giỏi vậy anh ạ
anh chạy ẩn thì được ông kia nói vụ chạy
ẩn nó ngon thôi rất là trải nghiệm người
dùng không tốt khi mà người dùng thấy mẹ
một cái nhạc phát ra từ đâu đấy thôi
cũng không biết tắt nó như nào thì chẳng
qua là mấy ông có thể các bạn học phải
CF rồi các bạn sẽ học phải size này
không phải dislike là nam hành án thì sẽ
ẩn đi hoặc là hồi trước có ông còn chơi
bẩn hơn mấy ông cho with 2 này cho là
không ngờ nạn như thế thì thì nó nói ẩn
ý thôi đúng không ạ Đây ạ
gì tương tự thế với thằng YouTube không
ạ thì các bạn sẽ có thể cách để nhúng
được một like YouTube về bạn cả Tự động
phát nó như thế nào Vân Vân Vân
thôi tự nhiên lại đang nói bắt đầu đi
Hơi xa nhưng tạm dừng đây đã nhé xe tải
thì mấy ông sẽ hiểu được cách Tại sao
tôi nhúng được v lít như này bởi vì nếu
mà các bạn như tôi vừa nói mấy ông lên
SoundCloud thì mấy ông chỉ dùng được bài
hát thôi không giống như Paris đâu
à à
ờ ờ
I và II desu làm ở phía client thì dễ
lắc lắm hả anh ạ
Anh ở thì cái cây cái vụ và đấy thì mình
sẽ giải thích cụ thể là
cái Mình học ra quýt này sẽ
chủ yếu là để làm virus
Ừ thì Suite lại hoàn toàn với lại tắt
được ở trên máy người dùng Nếu các bạn
ấn vào đây à
thì các bạn ấn vào à sự ấn vào xay xếp
tinh này rồi các bạn tắt de suisse đi
như thế này rathmines là có ngờ nó sẽ
gần như là nó sẽ hoàn toàn ra quyết các
bạn sẽ không bị chạy nữa xảy ra không
ông dùng bạn ra quyết về virus nữa nên
mà
và đẹp không nên chị và đất ở mỗi phía
client
à còn các bạn muốn hiểu thật sự và đến
là gì thì đợi cuối cuối khóa học này các
bạn là không phải phản ở cuối khóa mà
chỉ cần quấy cái môn despite này các bạn
sẽ hiểu và đấy là gì
không Chó nhà mình đòi chạy vào nhà mà
nếu mà phải cho nó quen ở trong chuồng
đi
A tại mình chưa huấn luyện được nó quen
trong chuồng cái nó có duyên gì chó phốc
rồi Nó rên rỉ nhiều
cá mình phải chỉnh âm lượng lại cái độ
nhạy của mic bé đi một tí không nghe
tiếng chó vậy
Alo tra đến cái ngưỡng này cho tiếng bé
hơn một tí nhưng mà sẽ không mang tính
tròn nhé
em
nói nốt phần YouTube
mà ông vẫn Thịnh nói quà của YouTube và
bà xã
sửa cái này đúng không
cái này Thực ra mấy ông ấy chia sẻ không
bé ông ấy á
Hai tay anh bận
vì nó có cái autoplay ở đây rồi này
Em hãy tôi xuống nhé
em
chạy lại
cái cái vụ autoplay này
anh
alo alo alo alo alo alo
thế đủ to chưa
à Có sao vẫn hết cỡ
kéo to play này của thằng YouTube tôi
thì nó không hề có tác dụng gì cả đúng
không ạ mê mấy ông mấy ông thấy à nhúng
vào những ngày nó cũng có tự động bật
đâu ạ Không ạ
Mình nhớ không lầm là hồi đấy Mình phải
có một cách nách thì phải autoplay bằng
chú rùa và thay bằng một thì gì ấy
à à Nhưng mà xem ở trên lô cùng này nó
không không không được ơ nhá vừa rồi
mình thử autoplay cả soudcloud nó cũng
không nó vẫn không được
Ê mấy ông cứ thử thử cho tôi bộ này tôi
nhớ Thế autoplay ông ông đi Như này sao
bằng một đấy chạy thử trên ghế khác thì
bạn bấm chạy thử trên ghế hát béo thử
nhúng vào gan Chrome nhé
Còn vụ tai lý thì để tôi xem à à
à à
khi sex
Ở
đây ít này
Ừ cái này có nhúng mà chúng coi nó có
những mà có nhúng mà Thế em thôi bỏ qua
nhé ạ
à à
Ừ
cái vụ autoplay Thực ra là trình duyệt
hồi hồi đầy Tôi có tra và trình duyệt nó
thì như thằng Chrome đôi khi nóng sẽ
chặn anh không biết thằng điên rồi còn
thông minh về không Nếu mà nó bảo là cái
việc mà tự động phát như thế được ra
trải nghiệm người dùng không tốt hiểu Nó
bị bất ngờ đấy mở một cái phát thì đó tự
nhiên tiếng gào lên được gặp nhưng mà
cái vụ trước có những cái Trang nhiều
kiểu trang lừa kiểu chàng chính trị mở
lên Tự nhiên cảm An nó đập con mặc dù nó
gào lên bây giờ thế là người dùng trải
nghiệm người dùng thế giới không tốt
những cái điều đấy thành ra là
ôm nó sẽ cố hoàn toàn chặn mấy cái vụ
đấy trong mấy ông
không phải là nó ngu đầu mà Nó cố tình
như thế còn thằng nghe không biết đâu
như em nó cứ thích một mình một kiểu ý ý
khi con tim nhỏ nhặt
a vectơ bây giờ mình trả lời nốt cái lần
Cuội cái tơ nhé Thực ra là mình không
rảnh cái tơ làm như mình khẳng định là
tester càng biết về công nghệ thông tin
thì càng tốt cho công việc các bạn bởi
vì mình từng quen rất nhiều bạn thế tôi
chị đúng bảy tám triệu nhưng mà cũng
quen rất nhiều bạn lương lên ngày 12 13
triệu có khi mà bạn đấy bảo là bạn biết
thêm về axwell biết thêm về lập trình
thể mà biết thêm mình mấy câu truy vấn
để mà kiểm tra được không chỉ kiểm tra
về bấm bấm mấy cái nút mà sẽ viết được
test cây tưởng thứ này test-unit có cứ
thế mình nghĩ à cái tơ càng thêm kinh
nghiệm với càng tốt
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Mình nhớ có cái vụ là kiểu
How to play nhưng mà nó không cho tự
động phát tiếng
Ừ ok trả lời tương đối xong hết rồi Hôm
nay mình sẽ vào buổi họp đầu ạ thì được
tia là hôm nay học phải ra Switch thì
cái mục đích học ra quýt để làm gì không
ạ
ưu tiên như mình từng nói tôi Buổi đầu ạ
thì cái trang web nó sẽ luôn bao gồm
HTML
HTML xương sống trang web về ngoại sướng
sớm thì sẽ chính là ra khi và Cộng cả mỹ
phẩm các bạn để cho cho nó cậu đẹp dấu
ngoặc thì ra Switch
nó sẽ là là để nó là kiểu cơ nó cắt dây
nó là các cơ để mà kiểu cho cho có thể
chuyển động như này vận động kiểu kiểu
thế chứ không thì nó sẽ được nhiên tại
một chỗ thì các bạn sẽ hình dung à ra
Swift nó biến một trang web từ Tĩnh sang
đập nên thế nay đều ngoãn vì thế trong
hết động nó là nó là gì và Tĩnh nó là gì
em không ra tuýt nó không hẳn não được
lão là theo kiểu lại để suy nghĩ này
không có nghĩ ngợi gì cả cái chị khán
giả là để đón triệu nó có thể nói về
chuyện động nếu mà các bạn sẽ có tham
mắc về cái vụ chuyển động đấy Có bạn bảo
với mình hôm trước rõ ràng em học xét
mình cũng có thể làm một thứ chuyển động
qua hoover cơ mà đủ mặt các bạn bạn nhớ
không ạ Mình mình thử cho lại nhá ạ
à à ABC này không ạ Tại sao mình cho cái
sai nó là như thế này Áo sử khi hát một
server và thì màu sẽ đổi sang màu xanh ở
nhạc
đấy Như thế này sao rồi em rồi các bạn
bảo sẽ là em chỉ vào nó đổi thưởng sẽ nó
to lên nó kiểu chữ nghiêng rất là thứ nó
cũng hoạt động mà nó cũng chuyển động ta
ví dụ nhé Thực ra hoàn toàn các bạn dùng
sẽ có thể cho nó bay nhảy giống như kiểu
chơi rằng con mồi đấy đưa cơ khi thì các
bạn sẽ thắc mắc về vụ là thế thì trang
web cũng là trang web động với chị ạ Em
chỉ dùng mỗi xe hết thôi cũng làm động
được không cần phải ra Switch thì cái vụ
tĩnh mà động ở đây không phải ấm chỉ là
nói chuyển động kiểu bình thường như các
bạn đang nghĩ mà động ở đây nó là gì đó
là khi mà mình tải lại trang này
chỉ sau khoảng thời gian ở đó mình tải
lại cái trang này thì nó thay đổi về mặt
nội dung Giả sử là sử ví dụ nhất là là
sự cư dân trí mình vẫn thích dùng trang
trí bởi trang này chán tin tưởng như
kiểu ở nhiều người sẽ nghĩ rằng chả tin
tức thì nó dễ nhận được là không
cài trang này đúng ạ Các bạn thấy là
ạ bây giờ kẻ mỗi cái này đang chuyển
động nhưng mình không nói việc cái này
thì nó biến trang web này trong cái động
không phạt mà
để tui hiểm vẫn còn dantri.com.vn không
ạ một tiếng nữa các bạn truy cập lại thì
thấy bài đăng ở đây nó thay đổi đấu
ngoạn thậm chí là chính tả bà đang này
nữa tui ở bài cùng một bài đang này đúng
ạ Giả sử của ai đó sửa lại bài 3 ngày
sửa lại tiêu đề này đúng ạ thì các bạn
tải lại trang thì kẹp cái bài đăng này
nó lại thay đổi thì
Ừ cái việc trang web cùng một cái trang
web nhưng nó thay đổi nội dung theo thời
gian
thì các bạn nhớ khái niệm này nhá anh
Bởi vì chính mình cũng từng bị nhầm mà
mình tự nhận mình bị nhầm Mịch mình nói
thẳng luôn Mình bị nhầm cách đây hai hôm
mình vẫn còn bị nhầm thì khái niệm này
thì bây giờ mình sẽ nhấn mạnh lại cho
các bạn thì các bạn đỡ nhầm giống mình
đó là một trang web mà nó có thay đổi
theo thời gian về mặt nội dung ấy nó sẽ
là trong các động được ngọn nghĩa là rõ
ràng là có thể là bây giờ là 8 giờ thì
các bạn nhìn thấy nội dung như này nhưng
giờ sự của ông nào thấy sai chính tả gì
đó ông ấy pha uống sữa đúng rồi ông Tài
thì em thì các bạn tải lại trang thì
thấy cái trang này thay đổi thì tức là
số trang web mẹ chồng cấp động còn cho
phép Tĩnh là trang web chỉ có HTML thôi
HTML thuần thôi thì chỉ các bạn sẽ thấy
là nó chả mơ thay đổi gì cả trừ khi ông
nào vào trực tiếp thay đổi HTML Còn cái
việc nội dung ở đây thì người ta không
không viết bằng HM không viết bằng HTML
ở đâu mà cái này
buổi buổi khi mà dạy về ngôn ngữ lập
trình với P thì các bạn sẽ hiểu toàn bộ
Cái này được in ra bằng pp để in in ra
chứ không về người ta có bao nhiêu bài
báo thì có bấy nhiêu ông nhà báo ông ấy
ngồi cốt ra cái trang kiểu bài báo như
này đâu Không không phải như thế đó
Ngoại
ok Thế các bạn hiểu qua việc cái Gia
squish Tác dụng để làm gì rồi nếu còn
thừa ra các bạn nghe thấy nó vẫn rất là
mông lung nào ạ bây giờ để mình chỉ đó
các bạn ạ sử bây giờ đây chữ ABC không ạ
bây giờ sửa là mình
ạ
Bây giờ mình giả sử là mình muốn thay
đổi cái chữ abc này bằng ra Switch thì
như thế nào thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ có
thể Swift như này để ông ạ
à The sweep như này và mình sẽ
ghi đó của mình Chấm ghét Element là sẽ
ghét theo một cái gì đó nha Thì sẽ ghét
bay trong trường hợp này mình ghét bay
thừa mình sẽ thất bại idd
Ừ để cho nó chưa Thắng thật sự đây hay
đi nó ID bằng tựa
ở thẻ hát một chàng ạ ạ
A
solo.net em em mình sẽ đổi cái mình sẽ
đổi cái chữ a b c này cái chữ xy&z em ạ
Mình tại lại xa mà các bạn thấy là nó
đổi gần như là ngay tức Thủy không ạ
Ở đây các bạn gần như không thấy Cho A B
C gì cả đúng không Mà cái đoạn này tức
Làm sao bạn này tức là
để tui hát HTML của mình nó ABC nóng
lạnh nhưng mà ra Suite của mình nó chạy
nó sửa luôn cái thằng Có ai đi là như
này nó sửa luôn cả cái nội dung ở bên
trong thành thành xy&z rồi ông ạ
Các bạn sẽ thấy là HTML à giao tiếp có
thể sửa được HCM dọn ngoài ra ta ship có
thể sửa được cái gì nữa Nó có lời sửa
được cả
đây nó sửa được cả màu thật sự cho nó
sang màu đỏ cho nên đó thì các bạn sẽ
thấy là nó Speed có thể trình được cả
htpl cả sẽ đóng ngoặc 6 phải làm được
rất nhiều thứ và và chủ yếu nó sẽ thay
đổi htl và CS của trang web để trang web
nó kiểu trở nên thành trong bất động
kiểu tư thế anh
giống như thằng Facebook chẳng hạn học
Facebook của nó Các bạn thấy
các bạn Vào trang Facebook đúng không ạ
Các bạn càng nước xuống càng thêm nhiều
bài anh nữa đúng không ạ Lúc đầu trang
lúc đầu cha nhá các bạn để ý kĩ nhé Lúc
đầu trang cái cái Thanh cuộn của mình
chỉ chị làm đến đây thôi không ạ những
mình càng kéo thêm xuống nữa mình càng
kéo nên xuống nữa thì nó càng Tải thêm
bài đăng các thử thứ đúng ạ thì thì tức
là ra Suite của mình đang
bận bình tĩnh ra squat của mình đang tự
thêm HTML cho nó đúng ạ ạ
thì nó sẽ tự sinh ra thêm HTML nghĩa tự
sinh ra thêm những bài đang ở dưới ở
dưới nữa đái
một bể đây mình vẫn đang giới thiệu qua
về ra Swift nhé Còn bây giờ bắt đầu vào
buổi học đây bây giờ thực sự bắt đầu vào
buổi học
bị xóa đi à
à Thế bây giờ để làm việc và gia Swift
thì các bạn thấy là nó sẽ là thẻ súng
thể ra Swift như thế này the sweep ngọn
các bạn có thể là tách hẳn ra một cái
file mà file file demo chấm chấm chấm GS
kiểu Cứu Thế còn nhúng ở kiểu này các
bạn nhớ rồi nó nhúng kiểu internal không
ạ Các bạn nhớ vệ internal or external
không ạ internal
hãy Channel các bạn nhỏ không ạ
ngủ người xe của mắt và da suy Đương
nhiên cũng còn nhúng cải like luôn á còn
uống hết đấy có 3 cái 3 cách để nhúng ra
Speed thì thường là mình dậy yêu các bạn
thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn nhiều nghĩ cho
nô như mình đã từng nói rồi
em có
khi bây giờ mình sẽ dạy các bạn về đi
em dậy các bạn về thế là ngôn ngữ lập
trình thì cái đầu tiên cần cần biết của
ngôn ngữ lập trình thì đầu tiên là cách
khai báo biến khai vào biến ở trong
dress nó sẽ có thể dùng là rộn nét như
thế này à bằng ba thằng ạ
Cái lép mét là nó sẽ là kiểu
gắn gán biến cho biến bằng một cái gì đó
như thế này
các bạn sẽ thấy nó khác với cái hồi mà
các bạn học về moshe em ạ cứ suy thì sẽ
là a kiểu y này ở đâu in a hai mình nhớ
inna bằng 3 trả nợ
đúng ạ thì tắm chỉ là A là kiểu số
nguyên và nó bằng 3 đúng ạ em còn ra
speak thì nó sẽ không khai báo kiểu cho
nó mà các bạn cứ gán hẳn nghe luôn
một là loét hay dùng va được như mình sẽ
dạy các bạn về led thì lát nó sẽ
có thể dụng led hoặc dùng Va nhé nhưng
mà mình sẽ dạy các bạn về led các bạn có
thể tra led vế ta đợi một các bạn Hiện
tại sao nhưng mà thứ ba Thực ra lúc đầu
thì các bạn đôi khi là không nên tò mò
quá nhiều quá Nếu mà bạn nào mới học và
màu nhiều quá các bạn sẽ bị loại hung
tin và cực cả các bạn nghe mình nói cái
gì thì tạm biệt thế đã đủ ngọn
Ok ở đây khai báo số con khai báo về
chuỗi thì tao Ok mình có chuỗi ạ Mình
cũng sẽ cho chuyển ngay thôi như này
đây là chỗ ấy ờ
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là chỗ ấy nó sẽ nằm
trong một cái rồi ngày như thế này và nó
gán giá trị nó sẽ là dụng bằng dám không
được cho chị tự nhiên là kết thúc của
mỗi câu lệnh thì các bạn có chấm phẩy
không ạ
Ờ cái gán gan kiểu các bạn có thể dán
Yêu cầu là dùng nháy đơn hoặc ngày két
như này đều đường nhé Không vấn đề gì cả
Ừ
vậy thì gắn Gắn kiểu như này đúng ạ
à à a tiếp theo đỏ nữa thì các bạn có
thể nó quan về mạng
đây mình sẽ bỏ qua một tí phiên mạnh đi
sửa là mình sẽ cho mạng kiểu như này
mình sẽ chỉ dậy ba cái chủ yếu số này
chuỗi mặt mà mình sẽ không dậy về đối
tượng
tính ở trong cái cơ bản em mình không
dậy
mạnh thì nó sẽ gồm
một chuỗi nhiều giá trị cùng một lúc đầu
ngoan ví dụ là sự là một hạnh như này Và
thậm chí cả chữ như này
cả chữ có dấu được không sao k a
ở đây đây là cách hay bảo của một giá
trị các bạn thấy nó sẽ kiểu khai báo gì
cậu tự nhiên bắt buộc phải dùng một chữ
cái hoặc hoặc là
khi nó bắt đầu đợt đây nó sẽ khái niệm
đầu tiên nhé
bắt đầu là
chữ cái hoặc đô la
hoặc gạch rưởi Như Lai Nhưng mà thường
là không ai dùng cái kiểu đôla dưới nhé
nên mình sẽ chủ yếu dạy các bạn về việc
và khai báo biến hoặc khai báo
U23 biển kể cả biến dạng gì trong nữa
biến dạng mạng hay biến dạng số 2 biến
dạng chuỗi thì các bạn vẫn phải bắt đầu
chữ cái sau đó là số cũng được không cột
trong này không có kí tự đặc biệt đâu ạ
sau đó có thể chứa số đúng ạ
trong này không có vị có thể có kí tự
đặc biệt là kiểu gạch dưới như thế này
không mạch nha nghe điều đó ạ chị nó
không dùng được cách được mà không có
không có dấu được và có phân biệt hòa
thượng
Tức là sao khi gia sửa mình đặt biến A
như này như mình đặt biệt a viết hoa như
vậy thì nó sẽ là hai thằng khác nhau
đúng ăn gì
để hạn chế hả Cả
B3 ngay và ba như này thì nó cũng là hai
thằng khác nhau đấy bây giờ cách khai
báo biến có bạn thì bạn học được trình
chán chê mấy cái vụ này cho các bạn biết
hết rồi chứ mình đã nói cho những bạn
chưa hề biết ông ạ ạ
Ừ ok Bây giờ ba nói qua về việc khai báo
biến nó như thế nó hơi nhàm chán một tí
nhưng bây giờ mình sẽ thử đỡ hơn tí bây
giờ mình sẽ dạy các bạn về câu điều kiện
cài lập trình thì các bạn sẽ nhất là các
bạn biết phải biến là gì này điều kiện
này câu điều kiện này
và vòng lặp lại mình sẽ dạy các bạn về
những cái này
điều kiện thì nó sẽ là bản chất nó ít
theo nghĩa là nếu nếu
Ừ nếu nó đúng thì chạy và và nếu nó sai
thì chạy cái này cái gì đó là sự là ít a
b mình sẽ So sánh giờ sự A nó bằng bằng
40 ạ
So sánh đâu ai bằng bằng bố như này
thì mình sẽ lốt là thông báo là một cái
gì đó là a = 4 chẳng hạn thuế
Ừ anh ta lại này các bạn thấy nó không
hiển thị thông báo gì cả chứng tỏ ra
không phải bằng 4 đúng ạ mình đổi nó
bằng ba đi rồi vòng 3 này thế bạn thấy
nó y = 3 Ok đúng ạ thì bạn sẽ thấy là
cái điều kiện này nó sẽ là dùng ít này
rồi Trong đó có một trò này tôi cái này
kiểm tra các bạn thấy nó hai rồi ba như
vậy một cái bằng nữa hay là băng là để
mà kiểm tra
hai số bằng kiểm tra là là nó Nó kiểu so
sánh xem hàng ngày có bằng hay không đó
ngoạn chứ không phải gán giá trị nữa
a Air of nó chỉ dùng được trong trình
duyệt là để mà hiển thị ra một cái thông
báo cảnh báo ở đây
Screen lk là có trong này Có pin đấy à
em không có không phải dùng cái pin này
mình nhớ à Đó comment chấm Thủy
chị Mimi nhớ có cái Win7 cho mày cứ
sướng rồi ở đâu hình Drive phải nó
comment chấm dai đi
họ như này đúng ạ
à à
ừ ừ
xe tải nhớ Bây giờ giả sử là mình cho
so sánh với năm là em ạ Như này thì các
bạn thấy nó không ra một cái gì cả đúng
không ạ Nó không ra một cái gì cả Thì
bây giờ mình bắt đầu là nếu trong trường
hợp mà ngược lại đi nếu mà ít này sai
thì mình sẽ lại eo là trường hợp ngược
lại mình sẽ cho nó là a khác năm được ạ
ạ
do đó nếu bạn sẽ thấy là nó không để
thằng này không ạ Nó nhiều thằng này Đấy
cỡ bạn với ít eo
và cái này hoàn toàn thể kiểm tra thêm
một lần nữa là sửa mình sẽ kiểm tra nó
xem nó có bằng 420 trước khi nó nhảy
sang cái bằng 5 này
đúng không ạ
Đây mình sẽ kiểm tra nhưng một lần nữa
thì nếu mình kiểm tra kiểu nếu cái này
không đúng thì nhảy đến cái này dù mấy
người đến cái này thì mình sẽ là ít theo
ít vào đây như này à
cho
a = = 4 ạ
Mà đây sẽ khác năm và 4 đi
đó như thế này bởi vì bây giờ xử lý thay
nói như này thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ
phải nhảy vào đây nó sẽ sai ở đây đúng ạ
Toàn nó nhận nó nhảy vào đây nó không ở
đây nữa không ạ Anh đây là ít béo ít là
theo kiểu là à
đã kiểm tra lần lượt từ trên xuống dưới
và nó và nó theo kiểu lạc nếu nếu không
nếu không có thứ
Cái này có thể viết ngắn hơn là sử các
bạn Nếu mà thấy cái này nó dài quá theo
cửa các bạn ngồi ít kiểm tra lần lượt a
bằng bằng từ 1 đến 10 ạ Các bạn thấy
đoạn này nó sẽ rất dài các bạn có thể
làm cái khác bị tấu đi của email nếu chị
So sánh nó xích cây
si cây này à
Em thích cây này thì các bạn sẽ chuyển
biến ảo trong này mà các bạn sẽ So sánh
lần lượt ví dụ là nó bằng 5 thì sẽ là
của mình Chấm write
a = 5 đóng ngoặc
= 4 thì lại bằng 40 ạ Ở cùng thì à ra xử
làm mình xong chưa nhập cuối là mình
muốn
eo đúng không ạ thì nó sẽ là defoe là
tất cả trường hợp còn lại sẽ là a khác
nằm và bốn nhà ạ
sự đây mình 23 đi đây đúng không ạ
à à
ở
Đài Loan lỗi à Không chạy gì này à
Ừ để mình xem nếu mà các bạn đôi khi gõ
cốt thổi ra Swift mà bị lỗi như này các
bạn không biết lỗi Tại sao bà sẽ Ẩn
inspect ngay của hãng xe mà con show này
Đây nó đang báo lỗi lỗi lỗi Liên quan
chính tả bấm vào đây xem này à
Ừ ừ
đúng rồi đúng rồi mình không không Mình
đang chị các bạn với cái xem lỗi đã
thỉnh thoảng mình hơi bị ngáo một tí
những vậy Bấm vào đây nó không xem được
lỗi này hơi cay nhỉ À đây nó chỉ dòng
thứ 4 đúng không Trong một vài trường
hợp vì cái hiển thị số dòng rồi đấy nó
không nó không đúng lắm đâu Nên là các
bạn có thể bấm vào để xem có vẻ là cái
của mình đang một vấn đề không bấm vào
xem được
không Sao lỗi thì mình sửa mà không ạ
Các bạn đang tính mát hơn mình tạm thời
Thế đấy thì nó sẽ ra như thế này
nó sẽ ra là
Ờ nó sẽ ra như thế này nhưng mà ở đây
thích cay nó lại có một nhược điểm khác
với thằng ítelf kia để mình thử thay nó
bằng 4 thì có bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ in ra cả
a = 4 và tại nhảy cả xuống thằng dưới
luôn đúng ạ thì trong trường hợp này
Thích Ca Dù sao nó vẫn sẽ có kiểm tra từ
trên thùng dứa như thế này Nhưng mà nếu
mà nó đúng và trường hợp nào nó dính
nhảy thẳng luôn là trường hợp đấy và nó
chạy đến cuối luôn không quan tâm việc
là a có bằng bún hay bằng Bphone nữa bây
giờ sự mình cho nó bằng 5 thì các bạn sẽ
thấy à nó sẽ nhảy vào đây và nó sẽ nhớ
đến cuối luôn nên là cách để mà nó không
nhảy đến cuối Thế thì các bạn thể cho nó
blacknight nghĩa là nó sẽ ở đây và nó sẽ
ngắt luôn tại đây đúng ạ Nó sẽ không ngờ
xuống dưới nữa và cái BPhone này thì các
bạn có thể thêm Black chưa chắc cũng
được nhưng thường cái đến thằng cuối rồi
Nó không nhảy xuống hàng nào nữa thì
không cần để xem thêm Jax làm gì cả
đều ngoan đấy thì các bạn đây vừa rồi
Mình đã dạy qua các bạn về ít eo và
SwiftKey Thực ra các bạn có thể thấy nó
rất rất là nhanh nhưng mà đây là một cái
video có thể xem lại được đối ngoại và
sẽ có bài tập sẽ chắn sẽ có bài tập thế
nên là các bạn là Hãy chấp nhận nó rất
nhanh so với người mới học nhưng mà lại
rất là chậm so người học rồi đúng không
ạ mình khó mà cân bằng được cả hai giờ
đấy
tiếp theo là mình sẽ dạy các bạn
khi đọc Tôi nghĩ là có khi cho mày tập
trước đi cho tôi Tôi làm thử cho mấy ông
một ít bài tập cho mấy ông dễ hình dung
hôm này cho chị họ people như thế đã
bài hát viết này bạn một đấy à
à à
ừ ừ
ạ Bây giờ sửa bài tập là có đề đề Nó
kiểu như này để tôi tự chén đấy kế toán
công ty phải viết chương trình để nhập
lương tính thuế thu nhập và lương Dòng
vân vân thì ở đây bài toán là các bạn để
những cái gì quan trọng để ý cái đoạn
dưới này đúng là lương là 15 triệu thì
thì cậu bao nhiêu thuế đúng không ạ
lương 7 đến 15 triệu thì có bao nhiêu
thuế là lương dưới 7 triệu thì coi như
thế nó không ạ
hệ thống kê vẫn đang hỏi về autoplay
được YouTube mà thôi bỏ qua đi ừ
Ừ nếu phải mò đi Tôi chỉ nói nếu mà Mấy
ông vẫn chưa chạy được thì mấy ông có
thể làm sai hoặc thiếu xót một chỗ nào
đó bé bé thôi chứ không phải mò nốt đi
bây giờ các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây sẽ có hai
hay thứ mà mình cần cần lưu ý đúng ạ cần
chú ý đến nó lương mà thuế đúng ạ thì
cải lương này tạm thời mình chưa dạy các
bạn về việc nhập lương và được không ạ
thì mình sẽ cho một cái biến lương mà
biến cố định đi là sử lúc đầu lương là
bằng 15 triệu đồng ạ
tạm thời là ghi 15 ngày thôi không Không
cần phải thể hiện chữ chịu rồi đấy Sau
đó thì mình so sánh xem được lương nó
lớn hơn 15 lương và 15 triệu không này
em hãy lương từ 7 đến 15 triệu này lương
dưới 7 triệu mà mình sẽ in ra cái thuế
bằng 30 phần trăm của cải lương đấy đúng
không ạ
ở dưới đây mình sẽ là ít
đường này
bằng bằng 15 này đúng ạ thì có phải là
đó cũng mình right này
thuế bằng
thế bằng cái gì ba mươi phần trăm của
cái 15 đấy đúng ạ thì tức là nếu mẫu mà
rút Toán thì ông ông chỉ việc và nhân 30
thôi chia 100 ngon
chỉ có mình dậy bị đau nhưng mình sẽ dạy
các bạn mày cả Đon cả bom
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ có thể ghi như này cái
diện nối chuỗi của cái này giả sử muốn
có một cái số ở đây là sử mình có số 10
ở đây ạ Đây là sử mình có số như thế này
15 lương không ạ thì sẽ là lương này
nhân với 30 chia 100 ngày đúng
không không không còn nhân với kiểu 35
ngay đâu nhá Không Không Không Không có
chuyện đấy đâu nhá thì để sau đó thì à
Mỹ Nhân 30/100 ngày không ạ Các bạn muốn
một tin cái này ra và sự thế tôi chạy
thử máy ông em thấy là nó không chạy
được vậy nó lỗi lỗi đoạn này này này thì
ông xem này
Nó lỗi đây
như này lỗi lại dòng thứ 4 không ạ Con
kia cái chỗ này nó phải nối cái thằng
này để đi nó ra thì thì phải qua dấu
cộng như này đều ngoạn qua dấu cộng như
này nối chuỗi để cái này nó sẽ hiểu cái
này nó đa số nhá Nó ra là số như mấy ông
vẫn có thể nổi nó vào cửa ngày đó sẵn
sàng gia clip không có tiện kiểm người
ông ấy nói đi
kết nối kiểu
số với chuỗi theo dấu cộng ngay ngôn ngữ
khác thì ông cho kiểu này đâu
đấy Thế bạn thấy nó sẽ ra kiểu thuế bằng
4,5 triệu Kiểu như thế đúng không ạ
Bố mày 5 triệu nó sai đúng đúng
rồi đúng như thế chính nhờ cái này đúng
nhỉ
Ừ tôi không Nhớ tôi không khỏi tôi tự
nhiên bay não tạm bỏ qua gỗ toàn đi Hãy
tính máy tính tính hộ đâu mà mình nghĩ
làm gì đây Okay tiếp theo là
thuế từ 7 đến 7 đến 15 triệu đồng ngoại
thì mình sẽ e thôi ông ạ
Bình nhạc yao Ít lương
cái việc nếu mà 7 đến 15 triệu của ông
sẽ ghi theo tượng ngay bởi lương 15 điểm
ngay thế không đúng Và thậm chí thế còn
sai theo cậu ạ nhé Không được ghi cầu So
sánh rồi này nó chị so sánh được từng
đoạn 2 hai thằng với nhau Tôi không cho
sáng ban hành với nhau nghe được cái thờ
việc là ờ
về bản chất chống nội dung cái eo ngay
rồi thì mới không có thể làm theo kiểu
tìm việc làm
từ nhỏ hơn
từ nhỏ hơn nữa ạ Nó sẽ chuyển nhận lương
nhỏ hơn 15 này
Và và đương vào hơn bệnh như này à
Ừ cái việc
cái gì cả Và và như này tức là sao nghĩa
là thẳng hàng bên trái là thỏa mãn vào
thẳng bên phải này cũng phải thỏa mãn
khoảng 2 số 3 cùng một lúc để cả hai
trường hợp đều đúng thì nó mới nhảy vào
đây đúng ạ
Các bạn có hỏi gì thì các bạn cứ hỏi nhé
mình sẽ trả lời sau mình không thể vừa
dạy vừa xem liên tục được lỡ bậy nghỉ
Mình bị nhầm lớn hơn 7 ok
đấy mình chạy thử nhá
Vâng nha không thay đổi rồi mình đội nó
11 này đó thì nó sẽ bằng
ở cái đoạn này thì tôi giỏi toán cái
đoạn này tôi thấy nó chia 50 ạ nó dễ hơn
cái kia chia không phải lại 3 nữa chưa 7
bé có gì
tái thịt
Ừ Ok mở cái cuối này thì các bạn nghĩ
rằng cái cuối đối xin cho vài eo Nhưng
mà thực ra cái này nó hơi sai một tí
mình mình cơ thể cho bạn em các bạn xem
Tại sao sai nhá
là sử Mấy ông không đọc đề mà em cứ cho
nó vài eo như thế này ngon
như này tôi đội nón hàng chín triệu này
anh alo bốn triệu đi
2074 Nguyễn mười phần trăm mà đóng
Ừ nhưng mà yêu ngay sai bởi vì thứ nhất
à IELTS này có thể vượt ngưỡng được lớn
hơn lớn hơn 15 chỗ ngồi em thì có thể
lớn hơn 15 ở trong trường hợp này mà
đúng ạ Và yeo ở đây chỉ còn âm được tạm
bỏ qua phụ âm đi nhưng mà AE trong
trường còn mày lớn hơn 15 Nên là các bạn
vẫn vậy Bởi vì bây giờ giả sử nó thành
16 thì anh sai thôi Nóng bạn
Đợi mình tí được à
ờ ờ
em kết thì cái eo ở trong trường hợp này
các bạn sẽ thấy nó sai bởi vì à
thì nó sẽ ra kiểu như này nó sẽ nhảy vào
đây đông ạ
u-mac mình sẽ dạy ở trong cái ạ khóa học
này đấy nhưng mà phải đến khi nào mình
dậy sang bên vai date thì mình mới dậy
các bạn cơ bản về lí khách thôi Nên là
một là bạn tìm hiểu trước về khái niệm
với các bạn cha thường là tra thêm chữ
Toyo hoặc là 101 đấy Nó xảy ra à
anh
Lương nhỏ hơn 7
đấy phòng trường hợp này thì các bạn
thấy thực ra là cái đề này nó cũng hơi
sai thôi mà lương mà quá nữa 15 thì nó
sẽ không in ra thuế gì cả cái để gần
nhiều miễn thuế ở thế nhớ Đây chỉ là ví
dụ các bạn hiểu qua về việc ít Al và
kiểu kết hợp các thử thôi không ạ
bài này thì dễ bây giờ mới sang những
cái bài động rất dài dòng nhưng mấy ông
làm nữa
khi nướng sẽ phải làm cái bài như này
Ờ đây sử dụng xích cay để mà làm gì xảy
ra cái
5 âm lịch
đây Để ông sẽ mấy ông truyền biến vào là
là năm đầu ngoãn 5 số dương lịch gì gì
đó
mấy ông chưa học về cái vụ nhập input nó
cả bấm nút thì tôi bỏ qua nhé mày ông
chỉ việc in cho tôi việc là ông đặt tên
biển ông đặt biến là bằng con số năm đó
đúng ạ thì nó sẽ in ra Nó là kiểu 5 âm
lịch là gì đúng ạ Cái kiểu như này bằng
xích cây I
Ừ cái này nó đau não cực theo chỗ là mấy
ông Nga
Mi ông phải biết Qua nối Trỗi con thứ
nữa ừ
Ừ cái bài này tôi sẽ tặng B đấy Buổi sau
tôi sửa chữa
Ừ
thôi dậy mà ông ấy cái này đã
Ừ cái này cũng axit cây này nhập tháng 5
này đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ
đúng rồi bà đi dễ mấy ông biết lập trình
rồi nhiên thấy nó dễ Còn mấy ông chưa
Học Tự Nhiên đúng vát thấy bài đấy với
thoáng tự nhiên rồi
tôi sẽ dạy mày ông rồi cái bài này trước
thì mày không hiểu Cái bà kia
cái này cũng là lấy tháng mà năm đổ
ngoạn sông ngồi sẽ in ra là có bao nhiêu
ngày tối đa ở trong cái tháng đấy ông ạ
thì cái này cũng dùng xích cây bà cũng
kiểm tra rất thứ thứ thì ở đây mình
không quan tâm này nếu tháng nằm trong
cái khoảng này đúng không Thì ngày là 31
tháng 5 chấm khoảng này ngày 30 này một
tháng chia hết thì ngày các thứ đúng
không ạ thì tôi sẽ chữa trong mấy ông
mấy cái bài này làm mẫu
anh ở đây sẽ led đầu tiên tháng này là
sự tháng 1 này
tôi xin làm một mà lại năm này bằng
1997 này trở lại đây
đi thi à à
Em thích cây này
mình sẽ kiểm tra tháng thực là với năm
nào thì tháng tháng 1 nó cũng sẽ 31 ngày
chả bạn đấy đúng không ạ Có những cái
chỉ có những cái trường hợp tháng 2 thì
mình mới kiểm tra theo năm thôi đúng
không ạ
anh giờ đây mình cây này nếu trong
trường vào tháng 1 này thì cái ngày càng
ngay ấy đúng thì sẽ là ngày bao nhiêu
thì bây giờ mình sẽ cứ cho
mình mình thưởng mình hỏi dậy sinh viên
nó sẽ chuyển ngay chị sẽ
mình có cho led đi nét này bằng 31
Âm Nhạc
cho Sony Black này à
Ba
Tháng Hai tạm tạm bỏ qua tháng 2 đúng
không ạ
sau đó đi à tháng 3 có thứ ngoan
tháng 4 này 35 ạ ạ
Em có tạm một biến không cần giá trị
được mình có thể làm cái cậu nhà led
ngày như này sau đó thì ở đây sẽ bọn e
đi cũng được
ngày cũng hay cậu tiện hơn được phần
đông ạ tháng 5 này 31 này ra ra sự nha
lặp đi lặp lại đúng không ạ nhưng mà
mình mình từng thấy sinh viên mình làm
cách này Thực ra là cái nó 0202
cách cách cách cách này nó kiểu hơi bị
nông dân Vì mà không hề biết cách nó
ngắn hơn mình sẽ áp dụng cái này các bạn
sẽ để ngắn hơn rất nhiều này Xóa đi này
à
thì
mình sẽ cho cây một cây
3,5 này
7 này
8 này mười này 12 là ngày đều là ngày 31
và tương tự thấy mình sẽ có bốn này sáu
này chí này 11
từ ngày 30 chồng ạ Thế này là sau thay
vì các bạn phải tạo gần đấy Cái cây
thích cây à đẩy cái cây mà lấy ngay đúng
không rõ ràng tất cả các máy đều là ngày
31 mà đúng không ạ thì thay vì như thế à
Ông chơi chọn ngay nghĩa là tháng mà nằm
trong một trong những cái phạm vi ở đây
nó sẽ đều nhảy vào đây và được chú ếch
đấy thấy cái kiểu này nó sẽ hay hơn rất
nhiều đúng bởi tôi rõ ràng tôi ghi cứ
ghi ở đây mấy ông dễ nhìn thấy cái đấy
mà nó không ạ Đấy Tôi hạn như thế này để
trông dễ nội dung mà
mà bây giờ cuối cùng Mà bây giờ mình chỉ
việc kiểm tra thôi ít để mà tháng bằng
hai khá bằng hai rồi ạ cây hai tháng
bằng hai rồi năm
phần trăm bốn trăm tôi ghi hẳn phần trăm
bốn trăm ở đây Tại sao có khái niệm phần
trăm ở đây phần trăm nó là chia nó cũng
là chia nhưng mà chia là số dư đúng ạ
Chị lấy số dư dả ở trong trường hợp mà
dụng là ba phần trăm hai thì nó sẽ dư
một em ạ thì nó sẽ in ra làm Đi ra là
một thai ý là 1,5 chẳng hạn thế chúng ạ
bởi vì ba mà chia hai nó sẽ có thể ra
bằng 1,5
không ạ đi
ở nhà bé mình chia lấy dư để để mà kiểm
tra lại xem nó bằng không này hoặc từ
các có phốt đoạn lại nghen
khi tôi cố tình ghi thế thì có được đấy
ạ
khi sex
ừ ừ
Ừ
tại vì này à
à à
ở đây Cái này Thực ra mấy ông cũng không
cần phải hiểu lắm Tại sao nói như thế
mày không chỉ cần hình dung được là Ừ
thì cái đoạn này nó là phần trăm chia
lấy dư rồi các thứ thứ bằng không Thứ cả
kiểu nó chia hết Nó ngoan ý
à mà khác không Đây đây sẽ có khái niệm
này nữa nó khác không à
Ừ cái này là so sánh bằng bằng nhá Có
xoay sang đây So sánh khác này nữa không
bằng nó không ạ
thì nó sẽ chạy vào là ngày 29 ngày bằng
29 kéo
ngày bằng 28
Còn cái này ở liên quan đến tỉnh năm
nhuận rồi thì mấy ông kệ mình không cần
không cần phải kiểu hiểu tại sao có công
thức này không ạ Kệ thôi
Ê mày không Chỉ cần quan tâm việc là cái
phần trăm này nó là gì này cho cái dấu
này là gì ah Đúng rồi cả giống này nữa
gió này là hoặc này nghĩa hoặc là một là
cái bên này đúng hay là cả toàn bộ rồi
bây đúng Tại sao phải nói toàn cả toàn
bộ bên này vì các bạn Thấy có cái mặt
tròn ở đây này mà trò này để mà Nối hai
thằng lại với nhau và hai hàng ngày lại
qua dấu và Nữa tất cả lắm chị ạ Cái
thằng này bắt buộc phải đúng phải bắt
buộc phải đúng không ạ
Ê bà cái này lại nằm trong kiểu móc tròn
để mà so sánh với thằng này nghĩa là
hoặc cái này đúng hoặc cả cái cụ mày
đúng đúng không ạ Cái gì
Ừ đúng rồi mấy ông coi nói cấm thức để
mà tính năm nhuận tôi không để cần phải
công thức ở đây mà tôi Đề cập về việc là
mày không phải biết qua bị những cái
giàu này giấu này thì mọi ngôn ngữ lập
trình đều giống nhau thế là nếu mà ông
chưa biết về ngôn ngữ lập trình thì tôi
đang giải thích cho mấy ông đấy để mấy
ông về sau nhảy sang ngôn ngữ rất chính
xác nhận nóng chẳng khác gì cả à
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình sẽ nói chung lấy được
cái ngày đấy không ạ Thì bây giờ mình
chửi Năng ngày thôi thì mình sẽ dùng à ở
lớp rồi chẳng hạn
a
task force ở đây hoặc ra đó của minhdai
được của mình Chấm day
là
ngày 2.5 ạ Thôi cộng với ngài
như này thử nhé
ở đó
Đừng nghe tháng 1 thì nó thế tháng hay
sao mà đó sẽ ra 28 rồi vì không phải
không phải là Nhuận nó ngon thì thực ra
các bạn có thể làm cho nó kiểu trông nó
đẹp hơn một tí giống kiểu tháng 2 năm
năm bao nhiêu thì sẽ ngày bao nhiêu đúng
không ạ thì cách viết cách viết của
ss6e 7 mình không nhớ nữa viết theo kiểu
nó dễ dễ hơn nhìn như kiểu đỡ khó chịu
Còn Nhớ Hay cách viết kiểu nhà thì mấy
ông sẽ thích hơn đấy vợ dùng dấu huyền
dấu hiện cạnh cái số một nhé
tháng xong rồi dùng
ở đôla như thế này xông hơi hoặc nhọn
như thế này tháng như này
3 cách trèo này năm này à
em năm nay
có
xong rồi đôla tiếp này này cho này
thì mới ông sẽ thấy là cách viết kiểu
như này thì nó sẽ thay vì các bạn phải
viết theo kiểu gì này
thì các bạn cứ phải cộng như này
Sao lại cậu như này không ạ trong màu sẽ
khá là khó chịu khi mình cốt
các bạn thấy đương nhiên là các kiểu nhà
chồng vất vả hơn nhiều không ạ
ở
cổng nắng
lại cộng này nối chuỗi hiểu nha
Lại trợ rất khó chịu
anh ở đây còn thừa lại có hai cách để
biết
thì sẽ cách viết này cách nó kiểu dễ hơn
cái đôla dấu đôla hai dấu ngoặc nhọn này
cốt để hiểu được là đây là biến họ sẽ để
in ra được cải biến của các bạn
A và cái Dung dấu Hiền này để bắt buộc
phải dùng giáo viên này cái nhận diện
được là trong này nó có biến hay không
Còn không thì có bạn dùng nhái thường
hoặc ạ Ngày đốt như này cũng được Các
bạn nhớ nhé Đúng không thì nó ra chỗ ấy
còn còn cách theo kiểu viết dấu Hiền
kiểu ngày thì cốt là để mà các bạn có
thể in được biển ở trong chuỗi
xe tải thì đây một trong hai cách để một
các bạn in hình ảnh chạy thử Các bạn
thấy nó vẫn như nhau nhưng mà thấy rõ là
cái thứ hai trong nó dài dòng hơn và cái
thứ nhất này mình mình có cảm tình với
nó hơn
nhưng cái này là phiên bản của Swift và
phiên bản e62 S7 thì gì đấy Mẹ phiên bản
ra Swift cũng mới mới rồi đấy thì không
chạy được đâu thì nên là thế này là mấy
ông cũng
Nếu không mấy ông về sau cút ở trên một
cái trang bắt buộc phải dùng nghe thì
các bạn Khuyến không nên chơi cái kiểu
mới mới à
Ừ ok vừa rồi Mình đã dậy qua các bạn về
ít eo hơi cay nóng lạnh các thứ
Ừ
thôi không có kén kỳ thị you như
như thế đâu mày không Đừng có nghĩ như
thế về nó không liên quan yêu cũ của tôi
nhưng mà
nhưng mà phải có một cái gì đó để mà các
bạn dễ hình dung đó ông ạ cá Khía lúc
nào vui mà không ạ ok Nói chung là hôm
hôm nay buổi hôm nay học sẽ chỉ biết về
ít eo và sikkim đúng không ạ
từ từ rồi thì thôi Đây nhạc lại vụ này ờ
ờ
Cho
tôi thời gian gần đây tôi mới cài vía
cốt không phải đứa nha khỏi vì miếu cũ
mà Bởi vì a kể cái tôi học bên thông em
tôi thể cài viết code để mà một Coffee
thon và dù là đúng Vespa hon thì cũng
Liên quan nhiều cũ thật
À mà tôi không biết Thế nên là tôi cũng
có hóc môn nơi đâu tôi cái sao tôi học
đâu
nhưng mà vì Gần đây tôi cũng bị
hết bản quyền cái
cái cái phần mềm cho đang dùng cái từ
đang dùng đây là tôi mới kiểu mở cái vé
cốc lên Xong rồi Tôi thấy vẫn thấy ức
chế nó quá nên anh tôi cũng thôi cũng
không dùng nó nữa tôi đăng ký cái mail
mới thì mà để mà kiểu kích hoạt lại bản
quyền cái này nè khuyên hợp lý ông và
mấy ông nên nên trân trọng là modoo
modoo của mấy ông làm được nhiều thứ lắm
Thôi không biết tới muốn nói với ông mẹ
mèo đô làm những gì chưa
ở
ga Tôi cũng tôi từng nói Tôi trải qua
nhiều mối tình rồi nhưng mà riêng bạn
yêu cũ đấy tôi cám mình tôi sẽ Thuyên
chết đi
Ừ Ok bây giờ nhảy qua về những cái gần
như là cái này ta sử Tôi ví dụ cho ông
một cái này
3 cách chụp
ảnh một bài kèn bình luận và xử ở đây
Tôi có bình luận một cái bình luận được
khá nhiều lời thích tôi cảm thấy cũng
khá tâm đắc với ghế bình luận này bởi vì
a kiểu mình xin Linh gái nhưng mà mình
rất là từ tế được cơ thể bệnh đợi tôi tí
ạ Có người giao hàng
à à
ạ alo alo
ở đây thi nói chung à
hai tay Tôi muốn xin lên bạn này đúng
nhưng mà tôi văn vở Tí vào tôi Cậu muốn
chụp lại cái bài đăng này kèm mũi cái
bình luận của tôi thôi Thì bây giờ áp
dụng kiến thức Mình đã học nào đúng ạ
Mình sẽ inspect ở đây này ạ
ờ ờ
vậy để cửa sổ cái này đi Sau đó thì mình
ấn ở đây mình chọn và cái đoạn này
ở đây này
Vì sao nó thì tôi à ấn delete xóa đi như
này thấy ổn thôi thế tôi xóa được cái
bình luận của tôi ở trên bình luận trên
của tôi không ạ sau đó thì mấy ông một
là mấy ông thích thì xóa luôn gặp những
bình luận ở dưới dễ Chụp sau đó nhìn mấy
ông sẽ dùng một cái một cái tiện ích của
tôi cái thích a a
Em
chụp cả cả cái màn hình này
Anh nói như thế này
à à
[âm nhạc]
Em chụp cả như này nó sẽ đẹp hơn việc là
ông dùng cái cậu ông cố dung ra ông run
ra bé tí này xong rồi Ông chụp kiểu ngay
nhá Ông chụp kiểu ngay chữ của ông sẽ
không ngờ đọc được đâu đúng ạ
Ừ thì bây giờ mấy ông hãy dùng cái phần
mềm kiểu ngày để nó xảy ra được một cái
ảnh rất là Mít đấy xong với ông chỉ việc
tắt nó thôi
dù bé mê uống rượu vào cốc nó như thế
này sẽ ra đó
Ừ nó thế xong được dễ dễ làm ở đúng ạ
dự án Thế mấy ông có một cái cậu bài
đăng kèm theo bình luận của mấy ông
thích ở mái ôm
babystar khắp nơi chỗ nào
đấy à
ý kiến thức ấy mình không biết đúng
không HTML đây rồi má ơi
Ừ mình vừa nói căn xấu xí hết rồi cân
trong sẽ hết Nó không tốt bởi vì nó
không chụp được và xử mấy ông mấy ông
vừa run thấy mày ông sẽ bị hỏng hỏng chữ
ngay chữ nó bị mờ cái thư gửi ảnh bị mờ
ờ ờ tiếp theo là
là sử là tôi muốn tìm
bài đăng của ông này chẳng Hạ
khi bạn đang ngủ Hôm nay tôi tìm
tôi có chứ vẻ đẹp mộc mạc này tôi nhớ là
từ khóa này chẳng đúng ạ nhưng mà tôi
chỉ muốn tìm bài đăng của mày thôi ông ạ
Tôi đã ký kết cái tao mày đi mày ông dễ
nhìn
ở đây
ừ bây giờ có chừng hợp thì nó ra được
bày ra ở ngoài như ông thế là nó dễ ra
rất nhiều cái đôi khi không dính đến ba
đang của ông này đúng không ạ sẽ ra rất
nhiều cá linh tinh đấy Kiểu như hơn một
tốt này
Bây giờ nó ra rất nhiều cái linh tinh là
sử đạo tía không ra là cả bài Ông này bị
trong trường hợp này là bài này tôi
tương tác thôi đúng không ạ bài tôi chưa
từng tương tác tôi mới chị thấy lướt qua
thôi như tôi nhớ từ từ khóa này làm tôi
nhớ được cả cái người đang bà đấy chúng
tôi không Tôi không biết cách nào để xem
ạ trong trường hợp mà ông tham gia nhóm
mấy rồi thì mày bấm được vào như này ông
xem được Toàn vụ bài đăng này để từng
đăng nhưng mà đây là bài đang sắp xếp
theo là là gần đây nhất Đúng là có thể
trôi sự bài kia đi Vân Vân Vân đóng
ngoặc có rất nhiều lý do ở đây nói cho
ông muốn tra chỉ ra được bài đăng của
ông này thì như nào Theo Facebook nó có
cho một cái perform như thế này nhưng
mấy ông cha đưa tên rồi nha Đỗ Trần Công
đồ À
đây Mấy ông thấy nó sẽ ra mấy cái dốt
của Vân nó không ra đúng cái cứ mông cật
đúng ạ ạ Thế bây giờ giả sử là tôi cứ
bấm vào một cái như này cái sáng nó
không ra bà đang đấy rồi nhưng mà tôi sẽ
có một cái đường linh như thế này không
ạ vẫn chỉ cho mấy ông mày cái đường link
này đây với ông sẽ tra đi cốt
bay64 đ
ạ sau đó thì mày ông có dám cái đoạn
thực ra mấy ông chỉ cần dán đúng cái
đoạn bạn là đồng để kĩ nhá Nó có cái chữ
Peter này nè ông chị copy dùng cái đoạn
Phi tơ rồi con nhá nhìn này ông ăn đi
cốt
Ừ thì bản chất nó sẽ ra cái đoạn như thế
này nó là nó là kiểu cái đoạn này là ID
của cái cái người mà mình sẽ kiểu tìm
cho bà đang ngồi đấy thì bị ông cầm sai
cái đi của cái ông hôm này và thôi ngoại
thì cách để lấy lại đi như tôi từng nói
một là ông ông bấm ở đây thì ông xem
được ID như này chứ giờ sư trà sữa là
ông của con lúc đấy ông còn chưa nhìn
thấy ông có mỗi đừng Linh Facebook ở
ngoài như thế này
chú tiểu nhân trên này vẫn có đi đúng
không ạ nhưng mà
em Giả sử có một bạn nào đó tôi tôi thấy
già sự có rất nhiều là sự anh Tuấn ơi
đây là ạ nhìn à
anh không biết lộ thông tin nhạy cảm thì
không à Có anh gạo nhập cục cư em họ
nghị nhập
anh Kiểu như không có ai đi ở trên thanh
địa chỉ như thế này tôi muốn lấy ID của
anh đấy là Nhạn đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ
thay cái này bằng m này
anh em mình gõ mình gõ thừa chữ nữa rồi
Mờ này ạ
cho sò ấn vào đây này
em copy Linh Express này nó sẽ ra một
cái đoạn ở đây là đoạn à
anh bay bay chẳng ai đi anh cái này
ở đó sau đó mình thay ở đây ai đi ạ Thế
xảy ra được là chỉ lấy
mình copy Dạo này nhá xanh em cốt này
Ồ không tôi người dụ dỗ anh ấy biết chơi
phỏm đấy em tôi cũng là người có lỗi
thấy bỏ quay này đi
đấy so em Cốt nó sẽ ra đoạn này thôi ông
chỉ hai em cốt vào đoạn này có xong nhìn
này
ở đây nó sẽ cho toàn bộ những cái bài
đăng mà anh đầy Đăng Luân hơn Vân tượng
tương tự là không thể áp dụng cho người
khác nóng lạnh ý
à à
Em hãy để cách để mở Tìm kiếm bài đăng
từ một nguồn bất kỳ Nếu nó người thấy ai
đi đấy bếp hoặc là thuốc thì chắc là
không được đâu Lúc thì không có đăng
theo kiểu vú tao chỉ có mỗi là Tết hoặc
cả cậu một người bất kỳ thôi
ở cuối cùng Story mà không bị phát hiện
thì thực ra là như tôi từng nói là một ở
ông dùng cái tiện ích của chị Tư cho cu
ti thì nó có cái vụ à
Anh trả qua nó chặn chặn việc là gửi lên
xác nhận việc xem Sorry thôi nhờ ông
thừa có nhiều cách để nó lắng Nếu mà ở
xưởng chưa cài cái đấy thì có nhiều bạn
thực chơi Cho hỏi rồi đó kiểu mèo ma
Ừ tôi từng cho mày ông xem về vụ là kiểu
Mời ông vào xem Sorry tôi lại phải cho
em xem cái tôi bên thôi toàn gái mà
xe tải ở Network
Ừ nếu mà không Để ý kỹ thì nó luôn loát
được cả thêm những cái Story của những
người ở đằng sau nữa đúng không ạ thì
đúng rồi cứ thế thì trong trường hợp này
ông ông có thể bấm vào xem trước của một
bạn nào đó Đúng rồi sau một là tắt mạng
rồi ông hỏi ông tại Hàm cả nay về gì đấy
ông tắt mạng đi trông bấm vào đây cũng
được bởi vì cái này được bắt rồi Và khi
ông bấm vào thì nó bị đánh dấu đã xem à
đúng ạ
Cái kiểu như thế
nhưng mà cái cái Ở đây các bạn có thể
biết được
3 cách làm rồi đầu nhọn có nhiều bạn bị
biết được Mẹ đây rồi như sợ mình mày
không phải hiểu được bản chất của cái
đấy cái bản chất cái đấy Đó là việc là
khi ông toilet mồm cái gì đó nó sẽ dùng
Switch để mở kiểu bắt bắt được cái việc
ông bấm vào cái gì đó xong rồi nó sẽ đẩy
cái thông tin là ông xác nhận ông đã xem
cái gì đỏ lên
ừ đúng đấy thì bé ông phải chặn được cái
việc xác nhận đấy của nó thì nó sẽ không
nó nó sẽ cậu không à không để trong
thông báo cho mình chưa biết
có chuyện đấy thì cũng nói qua về vụ à
Không trước mình thấy có bài đăng
YouTube à nhầm Facebook cũng đang chuẩn
bị là kiểu không cho người khác
cũng không cho Facebook và hãy xa như ý
xa rồi đi xa nó đang kế thừa từ Facebook
mà hình như Instagram là không cho người
khác biết à
khi mình đã xem mình đã xem Story của họ
istar lúc đầu là nó độc lập từ Facebook
đúng
Ừ
thế như là thằng Story là sinh ra từ
insta sau đó Facebook mà mua lại Nó kiểu
nó kỳ thưa nó nhưng mà nó vẫn tách riêng
hai cái tính năng đấy nên à các bạn hãy
rõ ràng Story trên insta nó xem được
người lạ hay Vân Vân còn bố thì không ạ
Cái còn phẩm nhưng mà bây giờ bọn nó
đang chuẩn bị đường bộ lại thông tất cả
những cái đấy Thực ra cái đấy nó liên
quan đến việc là thằng ấy thằng lớn nó
thích thay đổi gì Việc của nó có người
dùng có khó chịu với điều đấy ý thế nào
cho nữa Gửi nhá
Ừ thì chính vì như thế Mình ở Dân công
nghệ mình mà khó chịu vì một cái gì đó
của một thằng khác khi mình dùng phần
mềm của nó như thế thì mình có thể làm
ra một loạt tiện ích như thế hay như
mình vừa trị các bạn Quà vì cái việc các
bạn chỉ cần biết inspect lẫn cả cái
Network này cho các bạn tìm hiểu Vì nó
các bạn hoàn toàn thể chặn được những
cái có chặn được nhá chặn được không bao
giờ nhìn thấy ạ Không ngờ gửi đừng dẫn
này lên nữa Chẳng được ai kiểu mình gửi
cho bạn xem nhé bấm vào đây này cần lấy
gốc đúng ạ Các bạn ở nơi đây ẩn blog nè
nó nó sẽ chặn nó sẽ không các bạn sẽ
không bao giờ gửi lên nữa luôn không gửi
việc xác nhận xem tôi đi lên nữa không
phải là kiểu bê tạm tắt đâu mà tắt vĩnh
viễn được luôn Nếu mà các bạn vẫn còn
chưa dùng đến trình duyệt này cái kia
như thế ư
ừ
đấy thế nên là các bạn chỉ cần biết tận
dụng giống như Thực ra tôi thấy nhiều Ôm
hacker cũng từ việc biết xem cái speaker
ẩn Network này rồi xem đó cứ kiểu cười
gửi thông tin có hứ hứ nhận thông tin nó
thử như nào xong mày ông mò từ những
thông tin đấy để nó ra được thông tin
nhận cảm 2 á Hay là kiểu tìm một lộ lỗ
hổng của nó vân vân để lách rất nhiều
cái anh Tuấn làm tiện ích cụ tiện ích
chưa tìm ra bản chất cũng ngồi xem cái
cái truy vấn này mà đấy thì tôi đang chỉ
em mấy ông về hướng như thế sẽ là mấy
ông mà dân công nghệ người ông thấy khó
chịu cái gì đúng không ạ thì mày ông một
là lại phải nghĩ ngay việc là làm một
cái tool phần mềm đó và tìm cách lách nó
mấy ông càng lách được thì béo vậy càng
cảm thấy mình ngầu trước đã rồi mới còn
chia sẻ để người khác nóng ạ Rồi mấy ông
cảm thấy kiểu
em không cần phải theo cái ngày này đúng
không ạ Mấy ông hoàn toàn rõ ràng hiểu
được những cái vừa rồi nó dễ làm như thế
nào cũng nhận ạ
ở thời đại công nghệ mà chúng ta phải sử
dụng đồ công nghệ một cách thông minh
hơn mình không thể bị phụ thuộc hết rồi
đóng Facebook khoe được một thằng nào
nữa bình nước mình khó chữa ông Facebook
chẳng ạ Mình mình làm nhiều cái nách Nó
mặt ạ
xe tải rồi mình nói qua khá nhiều thứ
nhỉ
nói chia sẻ khá như thứ rồi không ai
Chắc là tạm dừng nghỉ Hôm nay video gần
một tiếng 40 phút rồi à Thật
ra hôm nay bình bình luận hỏi họ nhiều
ấy bởi vì cho Hôm nay đông sinh viên hơn
thì
chắc là để buổi sau mình sẽ trả lời các
bình luận các bạn nhé
Ừ Ok chả các bạn ạ
Xin chào bạn nha à